our keys Pouncy speaking to reporters
yesterday was asked about some of the
criticism of Ben Roethlisberger and
recently Joey Porter who played with
Roethlisberger and had been an assistant
coach for the last five years had had
some criticism of Roethlisberger Pouncy
made it clear that there's just no point
in talking about it everybody knows how
I feel there's no reason to talk about
it and the one thing that I took away
from Pouncy and it's that that glimpse
into the mindset that the team is going
to have Chris all this dysfunction and
drama and all the criticism and scrutiny
is bringing them together in a way that
maybe they have never been together and
on the same page and if they can pull
that off
at a time when everybody is talking
about how great the Browns are going to
be this year and they're forgetting
about the Steelers and they're trashing
the Steelers and they're bad-mouthing
Roethlisberger this could be yeah I know
recipe not forced it works authentically
and organically and it all falls
together just right and the Steelers
could end up and I've said already I
think they're gonna end up winning that
division yeah it just it I can feel it
coming and and you know I don't wanna I
don't want to get short shrift to the
Ravens either but I think there's just
too much pressure on the Browns given
the division therein and given the teams
those established teams with that
championship mindset that both the
Ravens and Steelers have this is not
gonna be easy for the brown there's
something legit there Mike I mean your
guts right now you know I trust your gut
in a lot of ways and I think you know
you you know yet reading you know
reading between the lines the tea leaves
whatever it may be
yeah I think there's a lot of things
that you know even to me a guy that's
been around football I go yeah this
points to a team that could get you know
really close because of some of the
offseason distractions and I you know as
time goes on I'm more and more jumping
on the bandwagon with you and I do think
the Steelers can be really damn good
this year you know I'll say this as far
as the Marquis Pouncy thing Mike you
know offensive linemen they do seem to
love Ben Roethlisberger you know when he
scored when they throw a touchdown pass
they always pick him up you know I'm
sure the offensive linemen probably have
a little bit of a different outlook on
been as maybe compared to the skill guys
because you know the offensive linemen
aren't always looking for dialogue all
the time and being buddy-buddy they just
want to kind of a general to tell them
what to do you know he doesn't blame us
for anything and he doesn't make excuses
and then the
offensive linemen are bought in right
there so you know and I think Big Bend
from as far as getting hit in the pocket
or ever complaining about his protection
I've never seen him do it and I'm sure
the offensive line has great respect for
him because of that and you always got
to be careful of asking the center you
know I mean the quarterback Center bond
is pretty strong I mean come on the
quarterback sticks his finger in the
butt crack visual for those on radio on
a daily basis that's like it's one
finger I mean it's really you really
want that middle in the crack okay the
middle goes right in the crack so it's
that and you don't smell your hand after
practice cuz it's gonna be a disaster
okay but that's a special bond that is
what happens right there I'm sorry to go
off the rails and yes marques Pouncy has
been one that's always stuck up for for
Ben Roethlisberger yeah okay you guys
know where to I don't know where to go
from there and you know centers don't
wear cups in the NFL so it's it's
free-range down there it's free or it's
free fall and it's all free falling okay
down there so it's not yours times in
the NFL that's one of the big miss
nobody nobody does you get ridiculed if
you wear cups in the NFL it restricts
your movement exactly they want to shed
anything that will inhibit their ability
to move as freely as they'd like to move
yeah okay I'll take it somewhere else
even crazier what's amazing is nobody
really ever seems to get hit they're a
whole lot for a sport that's so violent
you know it's amazing how good your
natural reflexes are when you see
someone coming down to that region of
your body where you can just always get
a shift out of the way ho ho ho and they
never seem to get a clean shot there so
the cup you know has been proven not to
be necessary in football but it does
make the bottom of the pile a hell of a
lot more interesting that if you get one
of those guys I felt like that happened
more in college my college I found more
dirty under the pile stuff happen than
the NFL you know the NFL yeah the guys
were more professional and not indoors
playing those those type of games as
much as maybe some college guys were
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports